nature loves balance ever sprinkle salt
on a piece of eggplant over time the
eggplant starts to sweat out water
this happens because there's a different
ratio of salt to water on the surface
versus inside the eggplant so water
seeps out onto the surface to try and
equalize how salty the water is inside
and out this balancing act is called
osmosis it happens throughout nature
even in massive bodies of water like
where rivers meet the sea scientists
have been trying to harness the power of
this balancing act called blue energy by
sticking fin membranes in between
seawater and freshwater the holes in the
membranes are too small to allow water
to move through like in the eggplant so
instead the charged particles from the
salt move this flow of charged particles
can be harnessed to create electricity
in order for the charges to continue
flowing the membrane needs to be
selective meaning it should only let one
type of ion through this is
manufacturing the membranes relies on
nanotechnology it's often expensive to
build and maintain them and the system
can lose efficiency over time it's a
challenge to scale up these systems to
produce enough power to make them worth
the cost now scientists have built a 3d
Janus memory named after the mythical
God with two faces the Janus membrane
has different properties on each side
which makes it a good gatekeeper for
encouraging a steady flow of charged
particles from one side to the other
the membrane can be tuned to have
different sized pores and accept
different kinds of charged particles the
researchers measured how efficient this
process was at converting chemical
energy to electrical energy at about
35.7% it's better than a solar cell but
not as good as a wind turbine the team
hopes that Janus membranes can be used
to create more efficient and less
expensive blue energy generators these
systems can be deployed to generate
power in coastal communities that don't
have large enough waterfalls or strong
enough currents for other forms of water
power like underwater turbines
in order to find new forms of renewable
energy limit carbon emissions
researchers are looking into unexpected
places even tapping into salty solutions
[Music]